in this case in the case of rush of
causes Peter Bergmann and Ron Howard and
the actors but in real life as a person
Ennio Morricone The Beatles Led Zeppelin
I'm just you know look I can go on
forever
did I mention Beethoven did I mention
bath did I mention Mozart did I mention
calf track so you go in and said there
are only two types of music good music
and bad music and I think that's sort of
how I work
you know this stuff I love and it's all
an influence it's also in my DNA somehow
very the way it works with most
directors these days and I think it's
got a lot to do with that I work with
the you know same team of directors over
and over we meet very early on I mean
the the words the first thing the script
is there and you know we just have
conversations right right away and we
you know as s as I have a director tell
me the story or a screenwriter tell me a
story I start hearing a tone or sound or
I get an idea in my head and you know we
really start before they start shooting
the film
whichever one is in front of me right
now you know right now I'm staring at a
blank page and this is terrifying and
because you know everybody's always
clear how no you'll do it you'll do it
you'll pull it off and the only one
person who doesn't seem to know how to
pull it off as me so most the time I'm
just sitting there terrified so they are
pretty hard